captain people are afraid
I know we're not perfect the whole world
was wrong about you
we fight I could do this all day
hey youtubers it's Charlie so Black
Panther is here I just I combined all
the bits of Black Panther from the
trailer and there was another trailer
from the Kids Choice Awards that I just
I tacked on there were only a couple
extra scenes just more black panther
fighting so let's break him down I
wanted to talk a little bit about the
character his history and more
importantly how to pronounce the name if
you haven't read a lot of Black Panther
comics don't be afraid to try and say
his name out loud it's just touch Allah
it's very simple the way I say his
father's name is a little bit different
I know his father doesn't appear in this
trailer but he actually might be in the
movie his father in the comics is king -
Shaka I say his name like Shaka Zulu
black panther also has little sister
whose name is way easier to pronounce
it's just Shuri he also has an uncle who
briefly wore the mantle you see on
typically the mantle of Black Panther is
worn in a Petro lineage way as in it's
passed down to each king of the Wakanda
nation this next one might sound
familiar - there is an adopted brother
who's named hunter he's an older brother
but he's still adopted so think of him
as the Loki of the wakandan royal family
his name is the white wolf he wears a
costume that looks a lot like Black
Panthers but it's white he's the leader
of the wakandan secret police named the
hood sir Ozzy but as you'd expect they
do share that brotherly rivalry that
Thor and Loki share but it never gets
quite as crazy as Thor in locations
because they haven't got as much time in
the comics as Thor has there's been way
more Authority mcc's than there have
been Black Panther but a lot of that is
gonna be glossed over in Captain America
Civil War this is really meant to be
Black Panthers introduction and because
he is wearing the mantle of Black
Panther I'm wondering if before the
movie picks up his father will have died
and jacala will have ascended to the
throne of Wakanda option B is that his
father is still ruling Wakanda is killed
in the Stanford incident in the Winter
Soldier gets blamed so that's why Black
Panther is going after Winter Soldier
because he blames him for the death of
his father by and large what I'm
expecting though is a lot of the
internal mechanics of Wakanda will be
relegated to the black panther solo film
this movie will only brush over them
like what is the core concept of black
panther why does he have this suit and
why is he so much richer than Tony Stark
well the reason for that is because
vibranium so valuable
imagine vibranium being like the oil of
the Marvel Universe
it wasn't clear from this trailer one
he's outrunning Captain America and two
his suit is strong enough to deflect
heavy bullets although it's probably
gonna leave a few bruises so why is he
technically more powerful than Captain
America Super Soldier Serum not quite
equal to the heart-shaped herb that
Black Panther ingests that's what gives
him his strength and connects him to the
Panther God but think of his abilities
as being just like Captain America's all
of his natural abilities have been
heightened to extreme levels but instead
of flowing from science it comes from an
actual deity now because Doctor Strange
is introducing the idea of magic into
the Marvel Universe I don't really know
if civil war is going to address the
Panther God they might just tease that
and then wait for the Black Panther
movie to explain it just like a lot of
superheroes in the comics they have
changed the way his powers work just a
little bit like there'll be times when
he loses his connection to the Panther
God so he loses all of his abilities
then he regains them new riders come on
they try to add complexity to the way
his character works so currently in the
comics he also holds the title king of
the Dead and what that gives him is
access to all the experience and
memories and intelligence of the
previous Black Panthers so think of it
in like a Korra last airbender situation
where she has access to all the
abilities of the previous avatars let me
know in the comments though what are you
most excited to see from Black Panther
and Captain America Civil War and how
much of his family do you think that
we'll see do you think we'll actually
see his father I would not be surprised
if when the movie picks up he's still
Prince his father's alive gets killed in
the Stanford incident their version of
the Stanford incident then he ascends
the throne it goes after Winter Soldier
after taking the mantle a black panther
from his father Marvel's The Lion King
with the part of Skaar played by the
Winter Soldier Chadwick Boseman is an
amazing actor it's gonna be such a
badass I can't wait to see him think of
him is like a slightly more badass
version of Captain America way more
badass African ninja version of Captain
America if you do want to read a really
awesome black panther run that gets into
the minutiae of his day to day and all
the weapons and stuff that he uses
Christopher priest had a really awesome
run now just like a lot of Marvel's
titles they rebooted black panther so
also if you just want to jump on the new
stuff that's totally fine - that should
be coming out in the next couple of
months I think their timing
of things to launch when Captain America
Civil War launches but just to address
another moment in the trail that a lot
of you have been asking about Winter
Soldier looking like he gets his arm
ripped off by Ironman it looks like
during this final fight he tries to take
out Iron Man's arc reactor like during
during this fight and Ironman is able to
rip his bionic arm off people were going
crazy this morning but really it's not
that crazy you have to remember that
Ironman gets a new suit each movie he
gets a little bit more powerful so of
course as things look like they're at
their worst at this point in the movie
that we're cap says I could do this all
day that looks like it's gonna be the
very last fight of the movie so there's
gonna be a lot of collateral damage in
arms lying around on the ground do not
forget though new walking dead tonight
there's gonna be a whole lot of comic
book stuff so be sure to subscribe to
get that video I'll post it after the
episode airs not expecting any more
Civil War trailers for a little while
but there will be some more stuff
happening as we get closer to the movie
so don't worry there'll be plenty more
spider-man plenty more black panther to
talk about in the next couple weeks
while you guys wait for me to post that
video tonight you can click here to
watch the civil war trailer again and
you can click here for the Game of
Thrones video that I just posted thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you